Madam President I have the honor to
present to you and to the members of the
Board of Trustees the faculty in class
of 2010 of Barnard College who have
assembled here today for the
presentation of degree candidates I am
pleased to declare this 118 ceremony of
the presentation of Barnard degree
candidates now officially open it is now
my honor and my treat to introduce Anna
Quindlen chair the Barnard Board of
Trustees who brings greetings from the
board
I'm gonna wait for the whole class to be
seated
Barnard women of the class of 2010 I
bring you the warmest greetings today
from members of the Board of Trustees
who are honored and delighted to have
had responsibility for the college
during your years here we talk often of
our great future it is wonderful
one day each year to see our great
future spread so conspicuously before us
and I bring special greetings to all of
you personally we have something in
common today I am a member of the
graduating class of 2010 you're ending
your time is Barnard students and I am
ending mine as chair of the Barnard
Board we are graduating together but
here is something else we share we will
never really leave the classmates who
have surrounded us the faculty that have
illuminated the world for us the ethos
that guides us
we're also fused with them so that what
we do who we are what we become will in
some substantial measure have been
calibrated on Broadway between a hundred
and sixteenth and a hundred and
twentieth streets every column I've
written every novel I've produced every
position I've held in the public square
owes its genesis to Barnard College
because any skill I've acquired any
courage I've exhibited any intellect I
bring is a direct product of my
professors my peers and my place on that
campus I'm often asked out in the world
why we're still here women's colleges
are the only institutions of higher
education routinely asked to justify
their own existence no one asks why
engineering schools are necessary
or why over linen middlebury choose to
stay small yet over and over again we're
asked to account for ourselves in the
public square
just as we women are so often asked to
account for our own choices and to
justify the facts of our lives whether
we've chosen the fast track or the home
front or neither or both as the proud
chair of the most selective college for
women in this country I'm asked
constantly why we need single sex
education for women in the year 2010 and
I know the answer the answer is all of
you we Barnard women are singular the
women who are my friends from my time
here and the Barnard women I work with
on the board have an undeniable
ingrained sense of confidence and
audacity a belief that they will not be
stopped or slowed at Barnard I learned
that Elizabeth Bowen and Doris Lessing
or writers who should be taken seriously
but I also learned that I should take
myself seriously as a writer as well at
Barnard I learned that Simone de
Beauvoir and Mary Wollstonecraft had
opinions worth considering but I learned
that my opinion was worth considering as
well at Barnard I learned that there
were not enough women scientists
mathematicians elected officials and
jurists and I learned that we were going
to redress that imbalance not by
complaining about it but by creating a
new generation of women scientists
mathematicians elected officials and
jurists right on our own four little
acres and so we have and so we will we
take on the greatest city in the world
we take on the greatest city in the
world in the shadow of one of its
greatest research universities and
though we are small in size we prosper
mightily because we do so at a place not
where we need to fight the good fight to
be treated respectfully and taken
seriously but where our professors our
administrators and our sisters students
assume that we are formidable people and
so we are when I send a present to a
newborn I always include this message
welcome to the world well you are
definitely not children but you're the
youngest among us and so I leave you
with a variation of that message welcome
to my world
being a Barnard graduate will depend
demand the best of you it will make the
best of you too I stand here as a living
testimony to that fact Barnard changed
my life and now it will change yours
today we graduate together we go we grow
but we do not leave any of us
bless you all
Thank You Ana I am now pleased to
introduce Chelsea Zimmerman president of
the senior class presidents bar Dean
dumb Berg members of the Board of
Trustees faculty fellow graduates
parents relatives and friends I am
honored to be speaking to you today mom
please stop crying like all first
intense and passionate loves I remember
the first time I fell in love with
Barnard I had visited more than a few
appealing schools I walked into Barnard
Hall and was greeted by creative smart
artistic people they had an aura and
those were just the security guards
I looked at the other young women would
arrives at campus for move-in day they
were not from Minnesota like me they
could speak like native New Yorkers they
did not speak Midwestern I knew that
when I got that quizzical look after
asking if they liked puppy chow
they thought dog food I thought the
quintessential Minnesota snack filled
with chocolate Chex Mix cereal powdered
sugar and peanut butter
the Umbro jaw of the Gods and my
Minnesota isms were just one small
sample of regional variations from a mix
of women from 40 states and 19 countries
the crumbs of the crumb of one of the
most competitive admissions pools in
Barnard history I look out with so much
pride love and affection at you my
friends the class of 2010 gorgeous from
the inside out I look at you and I'm
still in love we have laughed cried
learned talked debated and challenged
each other and how lucky we were to have
such amazingly inspiring teachers
exuding curiosity and brilliance
I am so proud to be here as part of an
interconnected stream of women who have
excelled for my lifelong hearin Meryl
Streep who praises who Grace's us with
their presence today two women who have
graduated before our time women like
Anna Quindlen Twyla Tharp chief justice
Judith Kaye and Zora Neale Hurston we're
proud to be part of a Barnard legacy
that goes back to women like Margaret
Mead who talked to anthropology
department who talked about the power of
a small group of committed people who
had the power to change the world today
we stand in the shadows of the women who
came before us whose examples and lives
of inspiration have extended the
frontiers of what we can hope to
accomplish graduation speeches are
supposed to be grand moments when you
pause reflect and distill a mass of
experiences into something worth
remembering when people become slightly
haughty and awed by the majesty of the
moment if your parents or grandparents
and you witness the birth of one of us I
ask you to think hard and to drop that
memory and feel the magic and the power
of that moment
harkening back to and thanking you for
that moment as a modest Midwesterners
way of saying thank you parents for
giving us the gift that allows us to
stand here today in a way when
graduating from one of the nation's
premier women's colleges dare I say the
best birthing birthing is a parable for
what is about to come of us we have been
nurtured in the warm embrace of our
faculty who have taught us intellectual
discipline and rigor Tata said forever
answer there are but more questions that
yes we can we can drive do whatever our
hearts drive us to do we can realize our
dreams
we cannot only stand on the shoulders of
our mothers who have broken the glass
ceiling time and time again but we can
build our own castle in the sky a world
in which we are in boardrooms on the
highest course of this land in the White
House pioneering new science writing
plays and all the while raising our own
two or three perfect children with our
loving egalitarian partners yes we can
have a dream we are a long way from the
day back in the early 1960s when the
Barnard catalogue talked about how women
were required to wear pants or dresses
below the knee when crossing Broadway
for fear of how we might inflame attract
excite or be diverted by the young men
across the street we have come a long
way from the day when a college degree
qualified a woman to be a secretary or
as Justice Sandra Day O'Connor
experienced to graduate at the top of
her law school class into rather than
usual three years only to be offered a
position as a secretary in a law firm we
come here today ready to set the world
on fire and we are filled with uncommon
talents in our class to take just a few
examples our world's finalists in the
Odyssey of the mind competition to
trapeze circus performers while I'm
still waiting to see you perform on
Lehman lon three professional actresses
and a dancer with the Boston
Conservatory not to minimize the
accomplishments of Martha Stewart and
Margaret Mead we will leave our mark on
the world and so we take leave of this
place we love a for years filled with
memories big and small of cooking
misadventures and newly built dorm
kitchens resulting in numerous fire
alarms and new
renewed friendships with the
firefighters of engine companies 47 of
travel through our subterranean tunnels
when the construction of the Dhyana
Center forces underground for two and a
half years sometimes in our pajamas and
slippers we witness to historic
presidential inaugurations that of
President Obama on a frigid ly cold
January morning and president's farm in
a filled to capacity Riverside Church
President Obama urged us to quote pick
ourselves up dust ourselves off and get
to work and presidents far inspired us
with her vision of making Barnard a
world class institution for the study of
women's leadership class of 2010 let us
greet the future Barnard has equipped us
with the tools to tackle the unknowns
challenges that await us it's up to us
to use the tools wisely let us find join
what Barnard means to us now and will
mean in the years ahead
we should bask in the glory of this day
pausing to reflect and how we can best
use our bottomless energy and talents as
TS Eliot once wrote what we call the
beginning is often the end and to make
an end is to make a beginning the end is
where we start from the challenges are
before us let us rise to meet them
Thank You Chelsea that was beautiful I
am now pleased to introduce Elizabeth
Boylan provost and Dean of the faculty
who brings greetings from the faculty
good afternoon to the amazing members of
the class of 2010 and your families and
friends two distinguished guests of the
college and the platform party here with
me to our dedicated trustees alumni and
staff of Barnard who are with us today
and to my esteemed colleagues over on my
right on the Barnard faculty on whose
behalf I bring greetings all of you know
that Barnard is both a liberal arts
college for women and that it is more
partnered with Columbia located on
Broadway engaged with New York City our
academic programs likewise exhibit both
and features distinctive majors in the
arts that fuse both the study of and the
practice of the Arts an urban Studies
program that is both about and of New
York and a center for research on women
that celebrates through its annual
symposium both the scholar and the
feminist we celebrate to the lives of
people who might have and perhaps should
have come to Barnard those who share our
both and approach to the world one such
woman is Terry tempest Williams
currently the Annie Clark Tanner scholar
of environmental humanities at the
University of Utah whose website
describes her as both a naturalist
and fierce advocate for freedom of
speech who is committed to showing us
how environmental issues are social
issues that ultimately become issues of
justice author of books poetry essays
she has written this distillation of her
beliefs quote this is my living faith an
active faith a faith of verbs unquote
now which verbs earned a place in her
faith book here's a representative
selection for you to question explore
experiment experience
listen argue speak write read draw
provoke emote scream sin repent cry
cajole create confront confound walk
back walk forward circle hide-and-seek
to seek to embrace the questions be wary
of the answers unquote the statement of
faith of Terry tempest Williams to seek
to embrace the questions be wary of the
answers in completing your degree here
at Barnard you have embraced the active
life of verbs you have set your sights
high and accomplished much the Barnard
faculty and I have every faith that you
will continue both to ask the questions
with an avid curiosity and to
interrogate answers within informed
scepticism may you take from us and give
to the world what our mission statement
promises the self renewing intellectual
resourcefulness that is the mark of our
liberal arts education
and now I send you off through the
figurative Barnard gates as has been my
tradition with the words of Garrison
Keillor be well do good work and keep in
touch thank you I am now pleased to
present Katherine Palillo president of
the Student Government Association I
want to be a Barnard historian when I
grow up I've spent hours in the archives
poring over pictures and yearbooks and
newspaper clippings eager to learn the
stories of Milbank held and Mackintosh
I've become obsessed with a story of
Barnard it's one of discovery of
resistance and remarkable women our
College has been home to students who
have dedicated themselves to doing work
that matters our predecessors
established themselves and set the bar
for the strong and the beautiful and we
celebrate their triumph and recognize
their achievements often it may be
difficult to envision the illustrious
women who came before us as anything but
stately portraits hanging in seoul's
burger parlor but they were just like us
sitting at their commencement terrified
of life after Barnard
thrilled to go out into the real world
and overwhelmingly elated to graduate
from our school as we process in our
caps and gowns looking very much like
the pictures of graduations past I'm
reminded of the similarities we share
with our four mothers they spoke up and
spoke out like us they came to Barnard
with the same passion and reverends we
experience when we walk through the
gates for the first time we wrote for
bulletin we voted in student government
elections
and we met the physical education
requirement like they did it is in these
shared stories of life in our community
that I am assured of the glittering
future of 2010 our class is the next to
join the panorama of brave and
remarkable alumni and will do so with
courage and grace our foremothers didn't
leave Barnard and instantly become
legends but they did so because they had
the support system of their companions
they forged the same enduring bonds we
have the same community of belonging at
the same dominating sense of being a
group of like-minded leaders and
visionaries we are an outstanding group
of individuals who have lived and
learned in the best women's college in
the world we have enacted elaborate
power takeovers in reacting to the past
we've hosted cultural months art
showcases and midnight breakfasts and we
have repeatedly taken back the night
we've competed with the brightest young
minds in our classes in our clubs and on
our teams we've questioned Authority
we've broken through barriers and we
have been afraid and we have been
through the fear and we have defeated it
I'm not sure there's a typical Barnard
experience the hundreds of opportunities
for discussion achievement and
empowerment make it difficult to
generalise our individual journeys but
certain elements that are crucial to
developing in an environment surrounded
by brilliant and inspiring women bridge
the differences among our diverse
population much like the women before us
our path to the self our path to
self-discovery have been long and
winding with detours and stretches of
unpaved Road we've established community
in the absence of a Student Center we've
watched homecoming games and gone to the
gym and cheered on the best rebounder in
the nation
we've written for the spectator dance in
dozens of performances hit the campaign
trails and taught young children how to
read the women who attended Barnard in
its early years were prohibited by
etiquette from acknowledging and
interacting with the men in their
classes because they had not been
properly introduced today we kick their
butts
we are concerned not only how about how
well we do but about what good we do you
can quite actually spend hours in the
archives reading the individual success
stories and they are informative and
exhilarating but not comprehensive it's
this moment it's this threshold on which
we're all standing that can define us
there'll be decisions we'll have to make
and paths we'll have to take by
ourselves but it's what we fostered on
this campus that will sustain us when we
waver and are unsure what we have here
today can't be described as camaraderie
it's not a partnership we're not
affiliated with each other
and we're not a clique what we have here
is an undeniable sisterhood built on
late nights and early mornings of fear
and fearlessness of discovering and
trailblazing and pioneering the women
who were here before us held teas and
fudge parties and taffy pulling nights
before Thanksgiving we have been Athena
scholars we have researched water
samples in Bangladesh we have read and
digested manuscripts manifestos and the
mystique we've heard and met leaders who
have shaped the world in which we live
we've been inspired by the stories that
came before us and will be inspired by
the ones that come after we are already
devoted to Barnard history because we
are all part of Barnard history we are
passionate and supportive of the careers
relationships and dreams our friends
pursue and they are the legacy of
Barnard I have tremendous respect for
the women I've been fortunate enough to
know of my time here watching your
friend host a seven sisters conference
another friend choreographed performance
after performance
another friend gather personal
interviews for her thesis inspires you
to be better we are surrounded by high
achieving inquisitive young women who
are driven and passionate about
everything they do it's this community
marked by motivation and never settling
for second best that we leave today but
relocations and parting ways won't
dismantle our sisterhood because we've
gone through this together and each of
you carry a part of each other past the
gates and out of Morningside Heights we
carry other things to pride in our
roommates accomplishments the joy of
what we'll do with our opportunities and
the expectation that we'll call each
other to come out and celebrate our
collaborative impact on the world it's
been an absolute honor to be able to
compose with you our small portion of
Barnard history the shared memory of
what we did while we were here our story
will evolve and be crafted by the
incredible women of the class of 2010
sitting before me I wish you the best of
luck in your futures congratulations
thank you so much Katie
speaking of history in 1931 Barnard
established the Frank
Gilbert Bryson prize to recognize the
senior who receives the most votes of
her classmates for her contribution to
Barnard during her college years in
keeping with tradition no one in the
class including the recipient knows the
outcome of the balloting until it is
announced at this ceremony
this year's Bryson price is awarded to
like I should be letting miss Streep do
this
ami-chan
congratulations this is a great honor
and we all hope you take great pleasure
in it I am now pleased to present sally
davis and melissa Lasker co-chairs of
the senior fund committee
hello seniors over the last year we have
asked you to think about what Barnard
has given you we've asked you how would
you like to show your class spirit and
how would you like the class of 2010 to
be remembered you answered these
questions with an overwhelming amount of
support enthusiasm and spirit we are
thrilled by your generosity and your
commitment to our class and to Barnard
all things to be admired as a result of
your participation and desire to give
back we are excited to report that the
senior funds exceeded its $10,000 goal
giving us the opportunity to receive a
generous challenge from a class parent
and bringing us to an incredible sixteen
thousand one hundred and eight dollars
this money raised by nearly 60% of our
class represents one of the highest
totals in the history of the Barnard
senior fund and will go toward our
legacy gift we are proud to announce
that our gift voted upon by our
classmates is the class of 2010
contingency fund the contingency fund
will assist incoming Barnard students
receiving financial aid with start-up
costs such as bedding clothes and other
costs essential to college life not to
mention life in New York City one of the
greatest and most expensive cities in
the world
our legacy gift will supplement
financial aid packages and will provide
future students with these much-needed
resources
take today to be proud proud of
yourselves your achievements your
successes and your legacy
we hope you'll look back on all the
wonderful and unique things you've
brought to Barnard and revel in the
knowledge that you are helping future
Barnard women leave their unique mark on
campus as well we are certainly proud to
consider ourselves a part of the class
of 2010 and could not be more amazed by
each and every one of you you are an
inspiration to your friends classmates
families and teachers and it is with the
warmest and most heartfelt of sentiments
that we say to you congratulations thank
you to both of you and thank you to all
of you
that is not only a generous gift but an
incredibly thoughtful and important gift
so thank you on behalf of all of us here
I am now pleased to present Alecia
Mountain who will offer academic
reflections on behalf of the class of
hello I'd like to thank friends family
and faculty for being here to celebrate
with us today and I'd like to thank my
fellow graduates for being here to
celebrate with us every day it's fair to
say that during my past four years at
Barnard I've fallen in love with America
and I mean deeply smitten ly
unconditionally in love in high school
at my most rebellious I had dreams of
going to college in some romanticized
foreign place I didn't really feel at
home in a country that seemed hungry for
war and scandal blind to pollution
inequity and the condition of the human
spirit I craved to be part of a proud
tradition and instead I was unsure what
it would mean to reach adulthood
womanhood personhood in this America now
it's been four years and I'm a Barnard
English major which I think has made all
the difference in my courses of study
each semester my professors reintroduced
me to the characters of our history and
I met America through its great writers
I read Adams and Jefferson who taught me
about the optimism of democracy and then
I read Frederick Douglass who showed me
some of its failings Emerson and Thoreau
explained to me the sublime and
transcendental majesty of the land we
live on William APUs a Pequot taught me
who would walk the land before it was
America Fitzgerald showed me wealth and
Hemingway wore well Morrison and Hurston
showed me the strength of women
Dickinson made me want to try and try
and try again to understand
Falkner taught me about bearing burdens
I could go on and on about them in the
same way that I talk about my wonderful
friends and roommates favorite
professors and parents because these are
the people who have taught me Who I am
New York is such a worldly cosmopolitan
place which is part of what thankfully
brought me to Barnard as global as it is
New York has also been a crossroads of
America this is where Walt Whitman sang
a joyous song of myself and Langston
Hughes replied I too sing America in our
time at college we welcome those who are
working to shape our country today we
saw Hillary Clinton in Barnard Hall and
we heard President Obama's inauguration
on the steps at Columbia we got to spend
our days with brilliant scholars many of
whom changed our minds
and perhaps trans to our lives and we've
become acquainted with those who will
write the next chapter in the story of
our society our classmates I'm not sure
what I'm going to do with my life yet a
lot of us aren't sure what we're going
to do with our lives yet I wrote my
senior thesis on a great American novel
Moby Dick in my thesis I wrote about the
philosophical sublime in Moby Dick and
sometimes even though I don't know what
I'm going to do I wish that I wanted
something as badly as a had wanted that
whale the sublime is that sensation that
comes with recognizing the vast
magnitude of the world we live in it's
the experience of witnessing infinity
it's the feeling of both terror and
delight at the same time this sublime is
to stand on the precipice of greatness
which is where we're all standing today
that feeling of Terror is important to
the sublime and it's okay to be afraid
guys but we have far far more to delight
in we're lucky that Barnard hasn't
with the skill compassion and curiosity
needed to step off that precipice
knowing we will land on our feet able to
pursue happiness in all of my
uncertainty about the future I still
feel that America is a place full of
infinite potential a nation that flown
itself into existence not so long ago
and that's something to be excited about
let's remember those who have taught us
in classrooms in homes and in books and
let's go out and do right by them and
let's do right by ourselves
congratulations and thank you
Thank You Alicia beautiful we now turn
to one of the most important moments of
our commencement the presentation of the
Barnard medals of distinction to
individuals who represent the college's
ideals of excellence innovation
intellectual curiosity and service
Alberta Wright a Barnard senior in art
history will present the citation for
Thelma golden Madam President I have the
honor to present as recipient of the
2010 Medal of distinction Talman golden
Thelma golden visionary of the art world
prize curator of Harlem creative force
on the New York Museum stage revealing
the unseen artists and challenging our
view born and raised in Queens
you loved art almost from the beginning
you visited museums as a kid and by the
age of 12 when you discovered that a
curator was the person who put those
things up your sights were set you
landed an apprenticeship at the
Metropolitan Museum as a high school
senior and in 1987 joined our Women's
College sisterhood earning your BA in
art history and african-american studies
from Smith after paying your dues
assisting and interning you took a
position at the Whitney Museum of
American Art in 1991 there just four
years out of college you began to make a
significant mark in an otherwise
male-dominated profession that mark
became a very big splash when you
co-created the Whitney's 1993 landmark
and hotly debated by O'Neal the
predominance of women african-american
asian-american Latino and gay artists
whose work you showed was as
controversial as it was
precedented your solo curatorial debut a
year later was no less fold and has
talked about still blackmail
representations of masculinity in
contemporary American art hit a cultural
nerve and you said fearless and
unapologetic in its wake
thinking outside the box about issues of
race and gender was your signature and
you remained it with the Whitney for a
decade the Studio Museum in Harlem
followed in 2000 and within five years
you were named to the post you so
brilliantly hold today director and
chief curator in your own words you see
museum as think tank exhibition is the
ultimate white paper Harlem as the
psychic art of the black experience and
curating as an active verb the truest
form of collaboration and they're on
West 125th Street with shows like
freestyle frequency and flow you make it
all happen according to one trustee
wherever you go in the art world
when you say Selma you don't have to say
golden today it is my personal privilege
to celebrate you along with the five
hundred amazing classmates here before
you for as we say a Barnard majoring in
unafraid thank you for inspiring us for
being such a powerful catalyst for
change and for bringing the narrative of
art and artists to new life
it is my great pleasure to present you
with the Barnard Medal of distinction as
I think you all know senator Olympia
Snowe was supposed to be here with us
today but as hopefully you also know
senator Snowe has never missed a vote in
30 years in Congress and when the
Congress decided on Friday to schedule a
last-minute vote this afternoon on
financial reform she decided that she
had to stay in Washington for this vote
so we miss her with us today she has
promised us that she will come back in
the fall but we would like to honor her
nevertheless by reading the citation for
her medal Katherine Kolbert director of
the Athena Center for leadership studies
will present the citation for Olympia
Snowe Olympia Jean Snowe United States
Senator distinguished public servant
tireless advocate on behalf of Maine you
have blazed a trail of congressional
firsts have you as you have earned the
respect of a nation you are born in
Augusta Maine to Greek immigrant parents
whose early deaths were a life-altering
moment of your youth raised by your aunt
and uncle in Auburn he graduated from
high school there and went on to the
University of Maine and a Bachelor in
political science in 1969 we set foot on
the moon as you took steps toward a
future in politics you started with a
seat on the board of voter registration
and in 1973 faced adversity yet again
with the death of your first husband
Peter snow what would have been an
insurmountable for many of us was an
impetus to you you were elected to his
seat in Maine's House of Representatives
and just three years later to the Maine
Senate the first woman to serve
in both houses of a state legislature
when you walked onto the national stage
in 1978 it was impossible not to take
notice at just 31 the youngest
republican woman ever elected to
Congress and the first Greek American
woman as well representing the 27,000
miles of Maine's second District you not
only covered a lot of ground but you met
first District Congressman John Jacques
mckernon he was governor when you
married in 1989 and you wore the hats of
first lady of Maine US Representative
and with your election to the US Senate
in 1994 where you carried every county
of the state senator Olympia Snowe first
woman in American history to serve in
both houses of Congress for 16 years
through to re-elections with wide margin
wins
you have brought undeniable skill to the
job you've shown us that one vote can be
a critical vote that building consensus
is a worthy goal and that the center can
be a place of both energizing heat and
light from women's health to Student
Financial Aid from prescription drug
coverage to welfare reform from oceans
and fisheries to campaign finance you
advocate for families and children and
the right to choose in all its
manifestations and as evidence today you
never miss a vote you have said I'm
always willing to be the only Republican
if it's the right thing and most
recently in the unfazed and measured
style that we've come to know you
brought that to bear on finance reform
you cross the aisle with more grace than
Ginger Rogers oh favorite daughter of
mine we are honored to embrace your
leadership to admire your intellect
integrity and dedication that have so
defined your service it is with
nonpartisan pride and unequivocal
pleasure that we proclaim to the heights
of Mount Katahdin your inspiring place
in history
we're gonna hold her medal until she
shows up okay Hillary Callahan Barnard
professor of biological sciences will
present the citation for Shirley
Tilghman Madam President I have the
honor to present as recipient of the
2010 our nerd Medal of distinction
Shirley Tilghman Shirley Marie Tillman
academic leader groundbreaking scientist
first woman ever at Princeton's helm
we thank Ocana de your home and native
land for it was there in Toronto that
you got your embryonic start and at
Queen's University your honors
Bachelor of Science in chemistry two
years in Sierra Leone before you made
your way to the US of A you earned a PhD
in biochemistry from Temple University
in 1975 and stayed at Temple and the
University of Pennsylvania to teach
human genetics biochemistry and
biophysics during postdoctoral studies
at the National Institutes of Health
cloning the first mammalian gene was
part of your pioneering research in 1986
Princeton University beckoned and you
heeded the call professor of the life
sciences founding director of the Lewis
Sigler Institute for Integrative
genomics chair of Princeton's Council on
science and technology recipient of the
1996 Award for distinguished teaching
and beyond Fitz
Randolph gates an investigator for the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute a force
behind the human genome project a member
of the National Academy of Sciences and
Google's board of directors
Barnard's own distinguished woman in
science lecturer a recipient of awards
as numerous as they are deserved what
you have done for the culture of inquiry
the spirit of learning and all that is
Princeton is immeasurable in 2001 you
became its 19th president and in so
doing made history in your decade of
remarkable leadership in your lucky
orange shoes you have continued to be an
advocate for women in science you have
instituted family-friendly policies
enriched the arts and created a
Neuroscience Institute you have
connected with students and campus life
and embrace the challenges of
globalization as always you champion
discovery and diversity speaking
candidly against old norms while keeping
a 264 year legacy in mind when Woodrow
Wilson
Princeton's first president of the 20th
century said that the object of
education is to enlighten strengthen and
make fit he foretold your 21st century
lead and today we join all who came
before and the multitudes who have
raised a root beer at the hoagie Haven
in the spirit of old Nassau to celebrate
the impact you have made on higher
education you have enriched the academic
community that we had Barnard hold dear
and we offer you our deepest thanks
it is my great honor to present you with
the Barnard Medal of distinction and now
I have the great honor of presenting the
citation for Merrill Street I'm
directing Meryl Streep Meryl Streep
legendary actor master of the voice of
women advocate for our causes quite
possibly the greatest virtuoso of your
craft of this or of any generation it's
as if being born in Summit New Jersey
was a clue to how high you would rise
from cheerleader and homecoming queen to
coon laude graduate of our sister Vassar
in 1971 from an MFA with honors from the
Yale School of Drama where you are known
for your range and intensity even early
on to New York's Public Theater and
Shakespeare in the Park your first film
role in Julia your first television Emmy
for Holocaust your first Oscar
nomination for the dear hunter and your
and your first win for Kramer vs Kramer
all within a decade of your Vassar
diploma a second Oscar for Sophie's
Choice a second Emmy for angels in
America and we all know the current
score sixteen Academy Award nominations
more than any actor in history
25 Golden Globe nominations with seven
wins another record SAG Awards People's
Choice Tony nomination lifetime
achievement and a Grammy nod for Mamma
Mia where your words here I go again
could not be more apt summing up your
magnificent career is harder than
mastering both bourguignon you've taken
us from present-day Manhattan to 19th
century England from Madison County to
colonial Africa from runway to kitchen
to convent the women you have
painstakingly rendered have struggled
with the drama of divorce the lore of
secret love the clutches of addiction
and forever etched in our minds the most
agonizing choice a mother could make but
we have laughed with you as well in your
turns is the Greek isle goddess the
French chef the icy editor-in-chief you
even animate well as Bart Simpson's
girlfriend and that fantastic mrs. Fox
you're perfect intonation always
astounds polish Danish Australian Irish
the subtle slur of western Pennsylvania
and your collaborations never fail with
Hoffman and Redford Brosnan and
Nicholson Eastwood and Tucci Hathaway
and McClane with each you demonstrate
that you're a chameleon at the core
inhabiting every kind of woman the
exotic to the ordinary with equal parts
realism and heart and you're almost
certainly the first female star who is
more luminous now than ever
who has soared past ingenue into a
broader cosmos we hail you too we're
almost done
for staying in the spotlight while
staying off page six esteemed and
beloved never a commodity we somehow
feel you're one of us meanwhile for the
women of the world their children in the
environment you have taken time and
energy to give of yourself lending your
voice to myriad organizations like
Partners in Health and equality now and
your work on behalf of the arts music
poetry regional theatre has enriched the
human experience for us all quite simply
you are one true thing we have learned
from your brilliant portrayal your moxie
your wit and humility from Jane and
Julia francesca and Miranda Joanna and
Sophie so today Meryl Streep
I am honored to present you with one
award you have somehow managed not yet
to achieve
the Barnard Medal of distinction
okay
dry mouth Wow thank you all Thank You
president spar MS golden president
Tillman members of the Board of Trustees
distinguished faculty proud swelling
parents and family and gorgeous class of
2010 if you are all really really lucky
and if you continue to work super hard
and you remember your thank you notes
and everybody's name and you follow
through on every task that's asked of
you and also somehow anticipate problems
before they even arise and you somehow
sidestep disaster and score big if you
get great scores on your L SATs or M
sets or SS or whatever and you get into
your dream grad school or internship
which then leads to a super job with a
paycheck commensurate with the
responsibilities of leadership or if you
somehow get that documentary edited on a
shoestring budget budget and then it's
accepted at Sundance and then maybe it
wins Sundance and then you go on to be
nominated for an Oscar and then you win
the Oscar or if that money making
website that you've designed with your
friends somehow suddenly attracts
investors and advertisers and becomes
the go-to site for whatever it is you're
selling blogging sharing or net casting
and six
yes shining hoped for but never really
anticipated success comes your way I
guarantee you someone you know or love
will come to you and say will you
address the graduates at my college and
you'll say yeah sure
when is it May 2010 2010 yeah that's
sure that's months away and then the
nightmare begins
the nightmare we've all had and I want
to assure you you will continue to have
even after graduation 40 years after
graduation got a week before the due
date you wake up in the middle of night
the paper due and I haven't done the
readings
if you have been touched by the success
fairy people think you know why people
think success breeds enlightenment and
you are duty-bound to spread it around
like manure fertilize those young minds
let them in on the secret what is it
that you know that no one else knows the
self-examination begins one looks inward
one opens an interior door cobwebs black
the lights bold bulbs burned out the
airless dank refrigerator of an insanely
over scheduled unexamined life that
usually just gets takeout where is my
writer friend Anna Quindlen when I need
on another book tour hello I'm Meryl
Streep
oh and today class of 2010 I am really I
am very honored and I am humbled to be
asked to pass on tips and inspiration to
you for achieving success in this next
part of your lives president's far when
I when I consider the other
distinguished medal recipients and the
venerable Board of Trustees the many
accomplished faculty and family members
people who've actually done things
produced things while I have pretended
to do things I can think of about 3,800
people who should have been on this list
before me and you know since my success
has depended wholly on my putting things
over on people so I'm not sure the
parents really think I'm that great a
role model anyway I am however an expert
in pretending to be an expert in various
areas so just randomly like everything
else in this speech I am or I was an
expert in kissing on stage and on screen
how did I prepare for this
well most of my preparation for this was
took place at my suburban high school
rather behind my suburban high school in
New Jersey one is obliged to do a great
deal of kissing in my line of work air
kissing ass kissing kissing up and of
course actual kissing much like hookers
actors have to do it with people we may
not like or even know we may have to do
it with friends which is believe it or
not particularly awkward for people of
my generation it's awkward my other
areas of fo expertise river rafting
miming the effects of radiation
poisoning knowing which shoes go with
which coffee plantation in Polish German
French Italian that's Iowa tallien from
the Bridges of Madison County bit of a
brogue bit of the Bronx aramaic Yiddish
Irish clog dancing cooking singing
riding horses knitting playing the
violin and simulating steamy sexual
encounters these are some of the areas
in which I have pretended quite
proficiently to be successful or the
other way around as have many women here
I'm sure
women I feel I can say this
authoritative Lee especially at Barnard
where they can't hear us what am I
talking about they professionally can't
hear us women are better at acting than
men why because we have to be if
successfully convincing someone bigger
than you are of something he doesn't
want to know is a survival skill this is
how women have survived through the
millennia pretending is not just play
pretending is imagined possibility
pretending or acting is a very valuable
life skill and we all do it all the time
we don't want to be caught doing it but
nevertheless it's part of the adaptation
of our species we we change who we are
to fit the exigencies of our time and
not just strategically or to our own
advantage
sometimes sympathetically without our
even knowing it for the betterment of
the whole group I remember very clearly
my own first conscious attempt at acting
I was six
placing my mother's half slip over my
head in preparation to play the Virgin
Mary in our living room as I swaddled my
Betsy wetsy doll I felt quieted holy
actually and my transfigured face and
very changed demeanor captured on super
ade by my dad pulled my little brother's
hairy for playing Joseph and Dana to a
barnyard animal
into the trance they they were actually
pulled into this little nativity scene
by the the intensity of my focus in a
way that my usual technique for getting
them to do what I want yelling at them
never ever would have achieved and I
learned something on that day later when
I was 9 I remember taking my mother's
eyebrow pencil and carefully drawing
lines all over my face replicating the
wrinkles that I had memorized on the
face of my grandmother whom I adored I
made my mother take my picture and I
look at it now of course I look like
myself now and my grandmother then but I
really do remember in my bones how how
it was possible on that day to feel her
age i stooped I felt weighted down but
cheerful you know I felt like her
empathy is at the heart of the actor's
art and in high school another form of
acting took hold of me I wanted to learn
how to be appealing so I studied the
character I imagined I wanted to be that
of the generically pretty high school
girl I researched her deeply
that is to say shallowly in vogue and 17
and Mademoiselle magazines I tried to
imitate her hair her lipstick her lashes
the clothes of the lies some beautiful
generically appealing high school girls
that I saw in those pages I ate an apple
a day period
i presided my hair ironed it straight i
demanded brand-name clothes my mother
shut me down on that one but i did i
worked harder on this characterization
really than any anyone that i think i've
ever done since I worked on my giggle I
I lightened it because I liked it when
it kind of went up at the end because I
thought it sounded childlike and and
cute this was all about appealing to
boys and at the same time being accepted
by the girls is very tricky negotiation
often success in one area precludes
succeeding in the other and along with
all of my exterior choices I worked on
what my what actors call my interior
adjustment I adjusted my natural
temperament which attended ten tends to
be slightly bossy little opinionated
loud little loud full of pronouncements
and high spirits and i willfully
cultivated softness agreeableness a
breezy natural sort of sweetness even a
shyness if you will which was very very
very very very effective on the boys but
the girls didn't buy it they didn't like
me they sniffed it out the acting and
they were probably right but I was I was
committed this was absolutely not a
cynical exercise this was a vestige of
survival courtship skill I was
developing and I reached a point senior
year when my adjust
and felt like me I I had actually
convinced myself that I was this person
and she me pretty talented but not
stuck-up you know a girl who laughed a
lot at every stupid thing every boy said
and who lowered her eyes at the right
moment and deferred who learned to defer
when the boys took over the conversation
I really remember this so clearly and I
could tell it was working I was much
less annoying to the guys than I had
been they liked me better and I liked
that this was conscious but it was at
the same time motivated and fully fully
felt this was real real acting I got to
Vassar which 43 years ago was a single
sex institution like all the colleges
and what they called the Seven Sisters
the female Ivy League and I made some
very quick but lifelong and challenging
friends and with their help outside of
any competition for boys my brain woke
up
I got up and I got outside myself and I
found myself again I didn't have to
pretend I could be goofy vehement
aggressive and slovenly and open and
funny and tough and my friends let me I
didn't wash my hair for three weeks once
they accepted me like The Velveteen
Rabbit I became real instead of an
imaginary stuffed bunny but I stuck
piled that character from high school
and I breathed life into her again some
years later as Linda in the Deer Hunter
that was probably not one of you
graduates who has ever seen this film
but the deer hunter it it won Best
Picture in 1978 Robert De Niro Chris
Walken not funny at all and I played
Linda a small-town girl from a
working-class background a lovely quiet
hapless girl who waited for the boys she
loved to come back from the war in
Vietnam often men my age
President Clinton by the way when I met
him said men my age mentioned that
character as their favorite of all the
women I've played
and I have my own secret understanding
of why that is and it confirms every
decision I made in high school this is
not to denigrate that girl by the way or
the men who are drawn to her in any way
because she's still part of me and I'm
part of her she wasn't acting but she
was just behaving in a way that cowed
girls submissive girls beaten up girls
with very few ways out have behaved
forever and still do in many worlds now
in a measure of how much the world has
changed the character most men mentioned
as their favorite is Miranda Priestly
the beleaguered totalitarian yet at the
head of runway magazine Devil Wears
Prada to my mind this represents such an
optimistic shift they relate to Miranda
they wanted to date Linda they felt
sorry for Linda but they feel like
Miranda they can relate to her issues
the high standards she sets for herself
and others the thankless Nisour the
leadership position that nobody
understands me thing the loneliness they
stand outside one character and they
pity her and they kind of fall in love
with her but they look through the eyes
of this other character this is a huge
deal because as people in the movie
business know the absolute hardest thing
in the whole world is to persuade a
straight male audience to identify with
woman protagonist to feel themselves
embodied by her this more than any other
factor explains why we get the movies we
get and the paucity of roles where women
drive the film
it's much
it's much easier for the female audience
because we were all brought up grown up
identifying with male characters from
Shakespeare to Salinger we have less
trouble following Hamlet's dilemma
viscerally or Romeo's or Tibbles or Huck
Finn or Peter Pan I remember holding
that sword up to hook I felt like in but
it is much much much harder for
heterosexual boys to be able to identify
with Juliet or Desdemona or Wendy in
Peter Pan or Jo in Little Women or the
little mermaid or Pocahontas why I don't
know but it just is there has always
been a resistance to imaginatively
assume a persona if that persona is a
she the things are changing now and it's
in your generation that we're seeing
this men are adapting about time
they are adapting consciously and also
without realizing it for the better of
the whole group they're changing their
deepest prejudices to accept and to
regard as normal things that their
fathers their fathers would have found
very very difficult and their
grandfathers would have been horde and
the door into this emotional shift is
empathy as young said emotion is the
chief source of becoming conscious there
can be no transforming of likeness into
dark of apathy into movement without
emotion or as Leonard Cohen says pay
attention to the cracks because that's
where the light gets in you young women
of Barnard have not had to squeeze
yourselves into the corset of being cute
or to muffle your opinions but then you
haven't left campus yet this guy I'm
just kidding
you have had what you have had is the
privilege of a very specific education
you are people that may be able to draw
on a completely different perspective to
imagine to imagine a different
possibility than women and men who went
to co-ed schools how this difference is
going to really serve you it's it's hard
to quantify now you may may take you 40
years like it did me to look back and
analyze your advantage but today is
about looking forward into a world where
so-called women's issues human issues of
gender inequality live at the very crux
of the global problems everyone suffers
from poverty to the age crisis the rise
in violent fundamentalist one
as human trafficking and human rights
abuses and you are going to have the
opportunity and the obligation by virtue
of your provenance to speed progress in
all these areas and this is a place
where even though the need is very great
the news is - this is your time and it
feels normal to you but really there is
no normal
there's only change and resistance to it
and then more change never before in the
history of our country have most of the
advanced degrees been awarded to women
but now they are since the dawn of man
it's hardly more than a hundred years
since we were even allowed into these
buildings except to clean them but soon
most of the law and medical degrees will
probably also go to women around the
world poor women now own property who
used to be property and according to the
Economist magazine for the last two
decades the increase in female
employment in the rich world has been
the main driving force of growth those
women have contributed more to global
GDP growth than have either new
technology or the new Giants India or
China cracks in the ceiling cracks in
the door cracks in the court and on the
Senate floor
you know I gave a speech at Vassar 27
years ago it was a really big hit
everybody loved it really Tom Brokaw
said it was the very best commencement
speech he had ever heard and of course I
believed this and you know it was much
much easier to construct than this one
it it came out pretty easily because
back then I knew so much I was a new
mother I had a and I had an account I
had to well I had two Academy Awards and
it was all you know coming together so
nicely I was smart and I understood
boiler plate and what sounded good and
because I'd been on the squad in high
school Ernest full-throated cheerleading
was my specialty so that's what I did
but now I feel like I know about 1/16 of
what that young woman knew things don't
seem as certain today
now I'm 60 I have four adult children
who are all facing the same challenges
that you are how it makes things tough
for your family and whether being famous
matters really one bit in the end and
the whole flux of time I know I was
invited here because of them how famous
I am and how many awards I've won and
and while I am I am overweening ly proud
of the work that I believe me did not do
on my own I can assure you that awards
have very little bearing on my own
personal happiness my own sense of
well-being and purpose in the world that
comes from studying the world feelingly
with empathy in my work it it comes from
staying alert and alive and involved in
the lives of the people that I love and
the people in the wider world who need
my help no matter what you see me or
hear me saying when I'm on your TV
holding a statuette and spewing that's
acting being a celebrity has taught me
to hide but being an actor has opened my
soul
being here today has forced me to look
around inside there for something useful
that I can share with you and I'm I'm
really grateful that you gave me the
chance you know you don't have to be
famous you just have to make your mother
and father proud of you and you already
have trouble - your congratulations
thank you so much Meryl for delivering a
speech that was as inspiring as it was
memorable I'm sure from all of the
bottom of all of our hearts we thank you
for being here and for being you now
Dorothy Denberg Barnard class of 1970
and Dean of the college will present the
candidates for the degree of Bachelor of
Arts so if I live to be a hundred today
will always be remembered as the day
that I shared a bill with Meryl Streep
and she was my warm-up act okay Madam
President it is my privilege and great
pleasure to present to you now the
outstanding passionate accomplished
environmentally and socially conscious
spirited and creative young women of the
class of 2010 I do so with mixed
emotions for we will miss them we
include some members of the class on
whom the degree was conferred last
February those who have completed in
this term the requirements for the
degree of Bachelor of Arts and some who
expect indeed have solemnly pledged to
complete work during the summer I shall
call only the names of those who are
present here today we wish the general
college and departmental honors could be
announced at this time but senior
programs are so diverse and the
examination period so brief that a
complete inaccurate list of honorees
could not be compiled for this
afternoon's ceremony diplomas for those
who have earned honors will be
appropriately inscribed with laude
magna laude or summa laude
departmental honors and election to Phi
Beta Kappa as well as all college honors
and prizes will be posted on the web
at this time I wish to pause and on
behalf of the members of the class ask
that we remember Aaliyah Phillips who
was awarded her degree in February and
whose untimely and tragic death on
November 10th 2009 has left a void in
the hearts of her family classmates
faculty friends and Dean's we remember
Aaliyah her passion for social justice
her intellectual curiosity her
generosity and her talent for friendship
the order of presentation will be by
major fields and candidates will process
to the platform as their names are read
may I ask all of you please to withhold
applause until the last senior has been
presented Africana Studies Emma in pick
Ariella chromes
sonia shad Robin also shouting is to be
withheld till the end American Studies
Stephanie Brown Natalie Denault Allison
Halperin
Jenny Rose Halperin Donna Liu Lucy labin
bean Ellen Miller
Miriam Miller Nicole Nalepa iris
Rodriguez Claire Sheldon
Rebecca Tuchman ancient studies Molly
fells ancient studies and anthropology
Renee Soto ancient studies in English
Caroline hammer ancient studies in
political science Molly Fox anthropology
Anastasia Bader Sonali Bhasin Emma
canden Laura Chen and Danis Elizabeth
Edwards Anna estvo iris Fernandez
Megan Holland Sarah Kim Samantha cope in
Devorah Labbit on
Serena Lee Marilla Lee Christine Maloney
Gilly Messer Kate miles Maya
Makka pakka Burgin Pearson Melissa
Rodriguez Sophie Shapiro and Taylor
Marley Weiner
Erin white
Ruth Williams combined major in
anthropology and human rights
Vernie bazooka anthropology and English
Carly left anthropology and film studies
Marisa O'Hara anthropology and theatre
Elizabeth no architecture Lydia Bharti
Rachel Blatt
Desiree Casone monique colas
Evelyn Ferreira Charlotte Furai Tania
Gerson gosh I'm sorry Erin Kennedy Linda
Lavin Allison Mackel bride Jacqueline
Mayer Sachi NASA tear
that's the first Christina Sanchez
architecture mathematics
Gertrud Freedman history and theory of
architecture
shali Ana Lopez art history
Emily Cheeseman Samantha child
Christina daily Peggy Abner Lindsay
Griffith Kelly Michelle Gerardo Tania
Isakov Christina Mandy Tara McDonough
Stephanie Neil
Jacquelyn Rogers Madeline sparer am and
estoppel Stephanie Terrace Jessica wall
art history with the concentration of
visual arts Madison Burgess Clementine
Gilbert Xinhua thong Gabriela Monsanto
Millbury boat Polk Bauman combined major
in art history and human rights Alberta
right art history and dance
Alexandra Duffy Asian and Middle Eastern
cultures Emma deeds Hanna Fitzpatrick
Abigail Kerbal Alicia Louie Catherine
Rooney
Chloe sir in ski Kanaka wada Madeline
Welsh Catherine Zhang Mei Fang Zhang
combine major in Asian and Middle
Eastern cultures and Jewish Studies
Laura Mokpo Asian and Middle Eastern
cultures in economic history
Nancy al shami Asian and Middle Eastern
cultures and environmental policy Sarah
Shull who fry Asian and Middle Eastern
cultures and environmental science
Michelle our tani combined major in
Asian and American Studies Aretha Troy
Maggie Kim biochemistry Risa her locker
when she jammed
Linda suin majors and biological
sciences Carlene Bateman Debbie Chen
Jessica Chen Mary Rose grata Ville
Catherine hog Natalie Hallet Sarah
beshal Annie Jeong Christine lacunae
Catherine Rosen ganyan Lauren Thompson
Miriam tow ass
Haley's aimer biological sciences and
economics for das Dawood biological
sciences and history
pooja davay biological sciences and
political biological sciences and
political science
Diana Lin Shu chemistry Renee Harris
Bianca la he Jie
Nicole Mizrahi classics Greek Karen Kwan
classics Latin jig nasha Patel classics
Latin and economics Carla Mechele
comparative literature Olivia pers
Heather low Alessandra marks faith Rusk
Lara Schilling down that wheel computer
science Daphne LaRose majors and dance
Jessica bacon Sharona Khan Merrill Lodge
dance and anthropology Loreen bubu Shion
dance and political science
Judith st economic history
Tiffany Tiburcio economic history and
Spanish and Latin American cultures
Gemma Corrigan economics Molly alter
Sarah Ashman Flavia bento - Faria Anjali
be Allah Mary Billington Lydia by Howard
Danielle child's prema
Chowdhury elizabeth cone Nelly - Ebba
Lauren divest urn Nisha guard and AG
wave
Kathryn Bois
Ksenia good soul Jennifer Hanrahan Sarah
Horvath Shira Jacobs Hwa Jung Jung
Johanna calif i calif Alice
Marsha Kaufman Morgan Earp etske Akhil
Kumarasamy
Nina Lakhani Nicole lamb Melissa Lasker
Lisa Lewis
Bingley ow Janine limb
Jacqueline more Oh Ellen a mayor Mary
Maga Nicole meter
Jessica Milberg hey do Chelsea Miller
Esther men marry mrs. Mizoguchi swen way
win jayati Nigam
hey you Peng Jennifer pesum Sonali
Pillai Isabelle Reuben
Elizabeth shocky saris moly
Rani so malgorzata
salties julia Surikov cuff Shelly
Steinberg Jessica Stevenson Stephanie
Stroupe Elizabeth Z
Samantha Tao Kylie to Kowski Tian Kim
trend
Connie Wong
Danielle Wiener Bronner Nathalie you
mean Lily
Yip economics and mathematics Jing to
sin you have Chen Jessica Lieberman Lucy
Zhang combined major in economics and
human rights Ruchi shot economics and
European studies Ashley Lang quest
Yolanda lang quest together and
everything they do economics and film
history
Elena Lecter economics and Italian
Florida quello economics and psychology
Natalia Cohen Eliana
varenka's economics in Spanish and Latin
American cultures Sabina barber Leia
Samia chu chi lon Torres Dara Silberman
majors in English Gillian Adler they did
Anthony north
Adriana Berg Alison bumkey Maya Campbell
Liana Kerrigan Yankee
Caitlin Clark Maya Cohen when it's
Cullen Quincy Devlin married Obi's
Karolina Domingues Amador see Rebecca
Douglas Rose DuPont Nicole Edison Ariana
Garber Rachel - car
Emily geo bean Elizabeth Gordon
Marissa Grossman Madeline Jory Elizabeth
Wang Jill Janowski Emily Khan Jenny
Leroy
Jennifer Mandel Jillian Marcellus Lauren
March marsh
Yael Matt alone
Elizabeth McAvoy Megan McIlroy Panna
oldsman caroline porter caitlin kuenzer
akshatha
Ramakrishnan julia Rheingold alexandre
rodrigues Jamie Rubinstein
Naomi Shack nurse Martha shiver Rick
Nancy's shown Eve Solomon Abbey stone
Sandra saucer Veronica she GL
Julie Wiener Samantha woo
Rachel Ziegler English with a
concentration in American literature
marry a man bur English with
concentrations in American literature
and writing alicia mountain jacqueline
Stosur english with a concentration in
film studies Cynthia sass Aunt Emily
cokes Shana Cornelius Arielle Carlin
Madeline Langley English with a
concentration in theater
Tamara Geisler Courtney Mitchell Wesley
Salazar Rachel Weisz English with a
concentration in writing Sara Blakely
Cartwright Lauren Ely Marissa
Masek cos M holic Julia Phillips mallya
Schumann
Abby sugar
Clarissa Wong
when when yang English and film studies
Jacqueline Dow English with a
concentration in theater and political
science Annette LaRocco English with a
concentration in writing and history
Hollis MacDonald English with a
concentration in writing and music
Katherine Hathaway environmental biology
Jennifer blaha Laura Dieffenbach
khamenei to bathe Arielle Lyon
environmental biology and French Thalia
Arbit environmental policy Emily
Blanchard and a law Megan McNally
Johanna pompe lova a Katie Aurora
environmental science Kara fields Tara
michalak sander Holly mentioned wheel
Samantha Roberts Elena's step 2 its
film studies Lucy Chang
Carolyn getcha s-- Jessica Salinas
Margaret
Oh film studies in political science
Rachel barber majors in French
Emily Baird Tatiana chill coughs Pete
Vanessa Gonzalez Shara growl Danielle
Jacob Cristina Paulette on Oh Madelyn
Rubenstein French and francophone
studies Melanie weniger French and
psychology Morgana David's German Bryce
and Ted Borg majors in history Emma
Brockway Julia Calabrese e Emily Chen
Karen Deskin Sarah Evans Julia Friedman
Mallory Garcia Katelyn gillies Gemma
hobble Annie Kennington Liang ginkgo
Sarah Kupferberg
Caroline Wang LAN Lee hailey Negron
Sarah panful Nina Roth
Chisato Sakamoto and salsa
Kirsten snicker Sarah Shore Alexandra
triumph gretchen van dyke esther
Weisbrot diana Wilson stage special
major in history theater and performance
Jamie Lubin Italian Elise Kaldur Ola
Cecily Wong Italian and political
science Francesca Pro cuchini
linguistics Rebecca standing mathematics
Emily Hathaway Molly Stein Elizabeth
Williams music Rebecca Greenstein
catherine hicks ethnomusicology Rihanna
Berkeley
Ashley Gregor Anna Perez neuroscience
and behavior man Bertrand
hyung Suk show nicoleff Coco Rebecca
DOMA Rochelle do gay Anastasia
Eriksson Jennifer Gilman aquila iron
Elzbieta Elzbieta oxic Olga Koval air
chick Larissa mattei Amanda Miller Dalia
Musharraf II Victoria Pato Rosa pass
Cooley Jennifer Paris eeny Tom our chef
Elizabeth Shelly Polina fer ABBA
Shilpa vasishtha Haley Becker le divan
Wang Diane you neuroscience and behavior
and Spanish and Latin American cultures
Zoe clein philosophy Shana Crandall
Margaret Chrome Gwendolyn diapered
Carrie Fuchs
Jennifer grows bored as me Murdoch
Hannah Perry Laura Rogers Jillian roogey
arrow visits Jillian Drake when Afghan
and norik Caitlin Patterson ryuko Suzuki
physics and dance
Glenna Clifton special major in
astrochemistry Gemma Walcott greens
political science
Ilana RJ Sarah arrow Elise Bergersen
Caitlin Brazil
Emily Crossan Jasmina dis Dora ditch
Alexis Dekker
Davina at waru Keely Faulkner Sydney
frosh Miriam Goldblum Sarah Hirshman
Christine he's on Nancy humor mazuma
Javaid sabina con sydney comp Rachel
language I my easly own Claudia Luca
taro Noel
Marcus Catherine Martin Brown Courtney
Muller Eleanor noble malgorzata table
Courtney presswood mahisha Rashid
Melissa repco Lawrence all teal Kathryn
Schulman Emily's Becker Kelly Anne took
Tony Oh Hannah Vogel Sharon for hit
Shannon winner chantez Wilson
samia's ID combined major in political
science and human rights Alison barkoff
port
Francesca over water
Kirsten shy
Rebecca sure Alison silvera combined
major in political science and Jewish
Studies
Eleonora four shots kaya political
science and psychology zenith maymays on
psychology
Ilana Adler Mina Azizi le Sheva Belen
Thalia Berkowitz Wesley Birdsall Katelyn
Blevins Catherine Chang Tara choic
Stephanie Curtis Rachel Danis Danielle -
Philip Oh Alison down
Naomi Ellenson Jacqueline sq Maria Evans
Lauren Feldman Ruth and fear burg Kenya
George
Rachel Gordon Simone grazi Laura green
Elia Johnson
Asuma Kapoor who I'm sorry
Ashima Kapoor me coke on Caroline Leonie
Esther Levine Melissa Loman
Sabrina Lopez
Natalie Lopez Barnard born to go to
Barnard de Nitze man chef sky Emily
Merkel Lauren mold our Carla Palacios
Sherina Prasad Ellen peeper Kaitlyn
Riley
Danielle Robin Alina Rodriguez Melissa
Rodriguez ELISA Rome arouse key Hannah
Schmidt
Kathleen SIA Hannah Silva Kalinda Smith
joelly Velasco Jane waterfall Courtney
Williams
Abigail wilfer's Amy Yong Ming Guangzhou
combined major in psychology and human
rights Tara banaji psychology and
theatre Anna Weinstein religion Eliana
for Zach no Ilana bosses too much
practice Lindsay leborgne simmerman
combined measure and religion and
Women's Studies Sarah shower Colburn
Russian mica harvess Robin Jenson
Russian regional studies Laura
Hendrickson Rebecca Kim sociology
Melissa Brito Sarah Chen Michelle Chung
Alisa tupiza Danielle who Whitney hoot
me and Lynn Rebeca Martinez Amira nauman
Stephanie Petula Laura sass Molly shear
Shana Siegel Veronica
Vasquez Kathleen Wong combined major in
sociology and human rights
Alexandra Woodward Spanish and Latin
American cultures Elizabeth Byerly
statistics
Amanda Rivera theater
Heather Englander Lily Finn Catherine
Fitzgerald Marie Huntley Heather Janie
Amanda rody combined major in theater
and women studies Melissa Macedo urban
studies Anna
Aaron's Emily viral Wendy Bermudez Anna
Brauer Suzanne chip King Kaylie Doombot
Malika ed quest
Marly Iike wits Constanza jacobs taka
ko-- kono and krasner Victoria Lehman
Lucia
Mattox Logan Mauro
Jennifer pine on a wagon her Sobrero
women studies Molly Alec vanity David
Chelsea Fraser Devon Shay
Raina sobieski Jaime young and now last
but certainly not least I am pleased to
present the senior marshals those
members of the class honored in these
ceremonies for their contributions to
the life of the college in its many
aspects and their service to the entire
Barnard community Anna Stephan's
American Studies
Sally Davis anthropology and music
Samantha Cooper Berg anthropology ceased
hater economics Allison Hodgson Asian
and Middle Eastern cultures Rachel
Simonson biological sciences Julia
Tolentino chemistry Lindsey McGee dance
and English
Kimberly woo combined major in
environmental science and human rights
Emma sees felt economics Ellie McNamara
economics
Charmian Ahmed economics and mathematics
Danielle Brown economics
ami-chan economics joy rez mobitz
English Alexandre Huber English Isabel
aroof Oh English
Rachel Wilkinson political science
Catherine O'Gorman political aside
political science
Cassandra agador neuroscience and
behavior
Megan manga narrow neuroscience and
Rachel Lobo history Marcy Level II
combined major in history and Women's
Studies Virginia burger French and
francophone studies Leonor Waldron
English with a concentration in writing
Lillian chargon Women's Studies Caroline
Englander theatre and Francis Comfort
Cole urban studies Mo's nah I'm sorry
combined major in economics and human
rights Judith Lomax psychology Chazelle
Lyon psychology and Spanish and Latin
American cultures land sand lamb
economics and psychology
Stephanie Velazquez economics Alexandra
Murata environmental science
Chelsea Zimmerman political science
Kathryn Palillo American Studies
you may now applaud as long and as
loudly as you would like
it is my privilege acting on the
authority delegated to me by the Board
of Trustees and on behalf of the Faculty
of Barnard College to present these
students just named at the Columbia
University commencement ceremony to be
held Tuesday morning for the degree of
Bachelor of Arts with all the rights
privileges and responsibilities
pertaining thereto
and now and now it is my turn to depart
a little bit from the formalities of my
role today and to offer a few more
personal closing remarks and I hope you
feel my pain because it is a beautiful
May Day you or your daughter or
granddaughter or sister or girlfriend
has just graduated from college you have
heard from the inimitable Anna Quindlen
and the extraordinary meryl streep
champagne and good cheer are waiting for
you just across the street and I get to
be the finale so what I asked my son can
I possibly say just keep it short mom he
advised just keep it short and so I
shall in fact I'm going to give you not
a speech nor even words of wisdom but
instead just a list stealing shamelessly
from the style of well a rather
shameless man so without attribution or
further ado I would like to present the
top ten things I hope you've learned at
Barnard thing number 10 I hope you've
learned that all of the interesting
questions in life have no right answers
that instead these questions what is the
meaning of life what is the relationship
between interest rates and inflation
where is the best falafel in Manhattan
exist only to baffle us and to push us
to search for answers even as we know
we'll never find them number ten number
nine I hope you have learned that the
joy of inquiry comes from the process
itself from seeing puzzles and building
hypotheses and garnering the evidence to
formulate an argument I hope you have
spent hours in the library or at the
microscope or behind the stage
frustrated and angry and convinced that
you'll never get it right and I hope you
realize with the passage of even just a
little bit of time that those were
actually the moments when you pushed
yourself to glimpse a little bit of the
truth number eight notwithstanding
numbers nine and ten above I hope you
have also learned that sometimes the
answer is just twelve or six point two
five or know that in other words there
are facts out there hard fast
irrefutable and irrevocable facts and
that it's your job to understand them
and to analyze them rather than just
relying on other people's
interpretations number seven I hope you
have learned that you live we live in an
increasingly global world a world which
does not in fact revolve solely around
the United States and in which US
influence is probably going to be
dampened over time instead diversity
entails engaging with and learning from
people who are fundamentally different
than you people who have very different
sets of beliefs people whom you may not
like diversity I hope you've learned
here is a critical element of building a
better society but it doesn't come
easily and it cannot be attained merely
by proclaiming it number five I hope you
have learned the meaning of agency that
each of you is not just a person to whom
things happen but an individual who
makes things happen I hope you have a
sense of just how
your agency can be but also that
greatness is not necessarily related to
size in other words I hope you've
learned that you need not make an impact
on the world by curing cancer or running
a fortune 500 company or writing the
Great American Novel instead you affect
the world with every decision you make
to take this job rather than that one to
donate to this cause rather than the
other to smile at the stranger you pass
on the street rather than look away you
exert power with virtually every move
you make it's your job to recognize this
power and to use it wisely
number four despite what I said about
globalization I hope you realize that
New York is still the best city on the
planet number three I hope you've read
Milton Friedman and Karl Marx and that
you know the difference I hope you read
Simone de Beauvoir and Betty Friedan and
that you understand something about the
women who gave you the rights and the
freedoms you enjoy today I hope that the
poets among you have learned the basics
of organic chemistry and that the
chemists learned to appreciate the power
and beauty of prose I hope you've read
Zora Neale Hurston and Anna Quindlen and
Mary Gordon and June folic Erie and it's
and that you never ever forget that
they're all Barnard women number two I
hope you have learned that you are the
future and that in that future you will
be paying from my Social Security
because the US government is going to
run out of money eventually that was the
intro to macroeconomics for those of you
who might have missed it and finally
number one I hope you have learned even
in the few weeks leading up to this day
that life moves faster than you ever
imagined it could that things you see
stretching out into the distant future a
career kids perhaps that book you want
to write your 20th reunion are actually
much closer than you think so grab the
time before you and the time you are in
cherish it use it and don't wait too
long to do the things that really matter
to you whatever they may be realize in
the beauty of this day that like all of
us you will grow and age and change so
use your time wisely and in the meantime
wear sunscreen thank you for being here
today thank you for being part of
Barnard
I would now like to invite the senior
class to rise and join in the singing of
the alma mater
when the
I declare this 118 ceremony of the
presentation of Barnard candidates for
The Bachelor of Arts degree adjourned
stay in place into the last graduate has
left their seat and we complete the
procession and then please also join us
back on the Barnard campus as we
continue our celebration
you